patients are lining up at jaipur's
largest government hospital they say the
ongoing doctors strike is making
treatment harder to get
there aren't any doctors in private
hospitals when we come to government
facilities patients are not treated
properly doctors do X-rays and even
suggest surgery
but say they don't know when they can do
it
doctors in Rajasthan state are
protesting a recently passed Healthcare
Bill thousands of them have hit the
streets demanding the ACT be repealed
private facilities have closed
disrupting Medical Services patients say
they're being forced to queue up in
overcrowded government hospitals or go
to another state Rajasthan State already
spends more than the national average on
public health and treatment in
government hospitals like these is
largely free the right to health act
makes pre-healthcare a legal right
making it the first legislation of its
kind in India
doctors say the actual Force private
hospitals to treat emergency cases even
if patients cannot afford it they
believe this will increase bureaucratic
interference emergency defines sarkar
how can the government Define an
emergency that's for the doctors to
decide the government should ask us to
help them make a law the ACT looks like
it's been copied from a developed
country which has good health care
infrastructure the government says the
ACT will expand existing Health Care
schemes and increase access to the
poorest people
sometimes poor people don't get treated
in either government or private
hospitals that's why it's important to
give it to them as a right so they won't
die because they didn't get treatments
if the government's covering costs up to
thirty thousand dollars then what's the
issue the government says it's open to
discussions but will not repeal the ACT
patients hope the deadlock is resolved
soon for now the plan to broaden
healthcare access has resulted in
restricting it at least temporarily
Jaipur Northern India